life originates in the soul which exists
in solid and loose forms stronger beings
have their souls held together in unity
infusing their unique personality and
power when the body is broken the link
to these Souls is severed exposing the
solid soul to the air when exposed Souls
burn like they are on fire
it makes sense then that the four Lord
souls were found within the first flame
they were the fuel but if the soul is
the source of all life then what
distinguishes the humanity we hold
within ourselves the truth is even
humanity originates from the soul it's
simply a fragment of the dark soul the
mysteries of souls crystals and
sorceries are deeply intertwined the
more you understand these things the
more control you have over them soul
sorcery is the art of controlling soul
power with knowledge just like we
manipulate fire with heart and instinct
and miracles through faith the dragon
school of vinhai' teachers and
researchers sorcery the great hero of
Vinh home is big head Logan a great
sorcerer and teacher to many students in
time however he tired from the attention
of others and donned a large hat to hide
his face earning him his nickname locked
away in a cage incense fortress we first
encountered big head Logan I have a
bright idea
suppose you set me free I'm old and
empty-handed but I could repay you with
knowledge and sorcery this place is
melting my mind the inactivity is
repressive
I'm saved and I'd love to resume my
travels but I must log a few things
first and I owe you a favor back at
filing shrine Logan treats you like an
equal and offers to teach you all that
he knows glad to see you alive as
promised I will share my sorceries you
really are very diligent on your journey
you'll find another sorcerer from ving
hime once rescued Griggs joins you at
filing shrine as another sorcerer who's
in your debt on the topic of Logan he
says this he is a true hero no the
reason I seek Logan is well it's really
my own conceit now isn't it this
sorcerer of in-home seeks Logan simply
to prove that he can it's clear that he
admires the man and strives to be like
him after you've proven your worth as a
student and learned everything that
Logan has to teach Logan mentions that
he has plans to leave as to where that's
unknown heading out are you I too will
leave soon undead or no I shan't stay
here forever you have great potential
don't go and die over nothing with his
debt repaid Logan leaves filing he tells
you his plans but he doesn't tell Griggs
who is left in the dark again oh there
you are just so you know master Logan
has left on his own again it seems that
he is still determined to find the famed
regal archives in Anor Londo I intend to
search for him and this is the last
you'll ever hear of Griggs hope that you
never see him again
sorcery is enhanced by understanding and
knowledge that's why Logan seeks the
archives a place built to proceed the
scaleless as a reward for his help
against the everlasting dragons the
knowledge contained there is beyond
measure Seth was born different from his
brothers who were encased in stone
scales that made them immortal safe was
a mutation an albino dragon who didn't
have the immortality his brothers
possessed driven by jealousy he betrayed
their secrets and soon after driven by
desperation he began the search for
immortality
Seath created six-eyed channelers to be
his eyes scouring the archives and other
lands for knowledge he created crystal
golems to retrieve
kids and maidens for his experiments he
does all this knowing that time is
running out
Logan once taught you that life
originates in the soul
that's why crystal homing soul Mastro's
towards it somehow crystals are linked
to the soul and so through the power of
crystals she finally finds what he's
been looking for ah the secret of
seath's immortality if you have fought
him and were in prison you must know
that Seath is a true Undead
different from ourselves his wounds
closed promptly and no mortal blow
effects him granting true insulation
from death it is an effect of the
primordial crystal a sacred treasure
pillage by seethe when he turned upon
the ancient dragons so only by
destroying the primordial crystal can
you so much a scratch is hide seath's
knowledge comes at a price
he finds a source of immortality and
hides it away but something changes the
other lords notice seethe locks himself
away in his archives and stations two
armored boars in the hallways channelers
guard the stairways and crystal hollows
are scattered throughout on top of all
that the archives now lead anyone strong
enough to a chamber with Seath himself
inside upon your death safe locks you in
a Cell with a bonfire knowing that
you'll be locked into a cycle within
that cell it's almost like he knew you
were coming but you escaped and ruined
the archives freely this is where you
encounter Logan again but he's not the
same oh there you are it's been a while
or were you just here this fascinating
place defeats my sense of time but if he
hurt my mind no matter out I can't
remember the death
he undead he was
the same knowledge that unsettled Seath
is affecting Logan there's some things
in the archives that should remain
unknown for the path to true knowledge
is cursed and the fate of the three
sorcerers in Lordran is something that
should be forgotten the less that is
known the better
you
you